[Música]
el año de 2017 como les comentaba estuve
a punto de dejar mis sueños
después de más de 8 años y hacer
muchísimos trabajos en relación a la
comunicación pero no remunerados ya me
había cansado ya había dicho hasta aquí
es un precio muy alto que estoy pagando
y aparte estaba trabajando en el área
administrativa que no tenía nada que ver
con la comunicación
entonces ya creía que era un momento de
dejar todo atrás
y en ese momento ya había hecho un
programa de televisión cultural había
hecho programas deportivos había hecho
coberturas reportajes pero yo quería ser
conductora de televisión y no solamente
conductora de televisión quería conducir
un noticiero nocturno titular
y por más que hacía por más que tocaba
puertas por más que hacía casting que
leía pautas que iba a un canal de
televisión iba a otro me decían que no
que yo no servía para esto que no servía
para la televisión incluso gente muy
cercana me dijo sabes que yo creo que ya
es momento de dejar este dedícate a otra
cosa pero esto no va contigo cuántas
veces hemos escuchado esto que no es
para nosotros levante la mano quien es a
quien ha sentido lo mismo y quien se
identifica con esto cuántas veces nos
han dicho que no nos han cerrado la
puerta la mayoría
por algo están aquí no
entonces
en ese en ese proceso de que estuve
trabajando incluso en una etapa en
cuatro trabajos solamente uno era
remunerado y los demás eran para ganar
experiencia en la comunicación cuatro
trabajos prácticamente no dormía y
dentro de esos cuatro trabajos había un
programa cultural programa deportivo y
aparte mi trabajo administrativo porque
decían que la de la comunicación no se
vive entonces tenía un
trabajo remunerado
bien pagado estabilidad económica
comodidad tenía mi horario mi aguinaldo
mis prestaciones y era una empresa
reconocida o es una empresa reconocida a
nivel mundial ante los ojos de las demás
personas pues podía hacer que ya ya
había alcanzado de alguna manera el
éxito y podía seguir ahí pero algo
pasaba yo no me sentía realizada
después de años de trabajar así y de
pensar que mi sueño no se lograría
por fin recibo una llamada y me dicen
que sí estoy dispuesta a cubrir a una
persona que era la titular de ese
espacio nocturno de noticias y que si me
interesaba cubrirla por 20 días
dije que sí
y pensé es la oportunidad de mi vida si
yo no lo aprovechó otra persona la va a
aprovechar
todas esas horas que pasé desvelando me
leyendo pausa pautas consumiendo
noticias haciendo casting durante 8 años
a veces a veces no comía porque de un
programa me pasaba al otro y luego a mi
trabajo administrativo y luego salía y
no pensaba en comer o sea realmente no
se me pasaba el horario
entonces cuando me hicieron esa llamada
dije es la oportunidad
y justamente en aproximadamente
septiembre de 2017 hago esos 20 días
y pues me va muy bien porque si había
hecho todo eso durante durante ocho años
en esos veinte días leí el doble llegaba
a ver noticieros y me dormí a las dos de
la mañana me levantaba a las cinco o
seis de la mañana a ver noticieros leía
editoriales consumía todos los
periódicos que podía porque yo quería
quedarme en ese espacio
con el paso de las semanas
me hablan y me dicen laura te
interesaría quedarte en el noticiero
como titular
fue creo que una de las noticias más
importantes de toda mi vida
a lo que dije que sí pero no fue
solamente que dijera que sí sino que
también me dicen sabes que ya te vamos a
pagar
el hecho de que te paguen por hacer las
cosas que te gustan
lo mejor que te puede pasar
entonces me quedo con el espacio
nocturno por decirlo así pues
prácticamente ya la otra persona que
estaba que había pedido permiso para
para salir y luego entras pues ya no
pudo entrar y en ese momento agradecí
enormemente a todos los que me dijeron
que no
agradecí que me dijeran que no servían
para estar en televisión porque eso me
dio la oportunidad de practicar más y
decir si se puede
estuve así durante
un año y medio en el espacio de noticias
estuve trabajando en el área
administrativa en esta empresa que pues
no tenía nada que ver con comunicación
pero me daba para comer me daba para
sostenerme y estuve más o menos durante
un año y medio saliendo de mi casa a las
7 de la mañana llegaba tenía hora de
salida de mi casa pero no tenía hora de
regreso a veces llegaba a las 10 a las
11 de la noche porque noticiero era de
89 y todavía lo que te quedabas éste a
ver cómo había estado y hacer la junta
de noticias
entonces no tenía la oportunidad de ver
a mi niña tenía mi niña tenía un año y
medio durante un año y medio
prácticamente no la disfrutaba no
convivía con ella mucho tiempo
justamente llegó esa oportunidad de
sentirme realizada de que me invitaban a
coberturas de que me invitaban a las
universidades de que hacía reportajes de
que era moderadora de los debates pero
yo no estaba disfrutando a mi niña
y justamente en ese momento
sentí culpa
y te vuelves a replantear si es correcto
lo que estás haciendo con tu vida si es
tu vocación si vale la pena si lo
principal es sentirte realizada y dejar
la familia a un lado si lo más
importante es el trabajo
hay muchas mujeres aquí
quien se siente identificada con eso
quien se siente identificada con tener
que salir a trabajar
con a veces los lunes no quieres
levantarte sonar la alarma y lo primero
que quieres hacer es apagarla
quien se siente mal porque a veces los
niños les no les preguntan mamá por qué
no te quedas más tiempo conmigo
se sienten así
y hay otra parte de ustedes que les dice
me tengo que realizar quiero cumplir mis
sueños
en el trabajo te exigen como si no
tuvieras familia y en la familia te
exigen como si no tuvieras trabajo si o
no
sí verdad
estuve pensando en todo esto que les iba
a compartir y en que mi discurso iba
mucho al tienes que trabajar para ganar
experiencia y dedicarte mucho al trabajo
si quieres realizarte en la vida y
cumplir tus sueños
estoy de acuerdo con eso pero estoy de
acuerdo en que debe de haber un
equilibrio y si nosotros no lo buscamos
no lo vamos a tener
entiendo que queremos sentirnos
realizadas
pero también entiendo que hay una parte
de nosotros que quiere compartir
momentos con su familia que quiere ir a
los festivales de su hijo que quiere ir
a los juntas de los padres que quiere ir
a las fiestas y que a veces el trabajo
es muy demandante cuando me empecé a
sentir así entreviste a beatriz ramos
quienes ahora la directora comercial y
de comunicación de la federación
mexicana de fútbol y le decía beatriz
cómo le haces
para no sentir culpa yo te veo
trabajando tomar llamadas
sé que tienes hijos cómo le haces porque
yo me siento muy mal y me dijo
nunca dejas de ser mamá
las 24 horas del día eres mamá tú puedes
estar trabajando pero si le pasa algo a
tus hijos eres la primera que va a salir
corriendo a protegerlos
la culpa es un estado
de tristeza
no les voy a decir que no la sientan ni
que le rehúye
hay que aceptarla pero hay que hacer
algo con ella desde nuestras trincheras
desde nuestro trabajo hay que alzar la
mano hay que alzar la voz para proponer
cómo podemos proponer cómo puede cómo
podemos decir
hay algunas estrategias que ya están
implementando algunas empresas por
ejemplo que el primer año de vida de tus
de tu hijo te del medio turno que salgas
a las dos de la tarde y que puedas
disfrutar ese año o año y medio con o
con los primeros meses de vida de tu
hijo
hay otras empresas que ya están
implementando las salas de lactancia hay
otras que están implementando salir los
viernes temprano a las 2 de la tarde en
tiempo de vacaciones
suena descabellado
y ahorita que se les estoy diciendo
probablemente pensarán que no es que mi
plaza no no creo que pase no
van a decir que no se puede implementar
eso en otro momento era inimaginable
impensable actualmente existe y puede
existir si ustedes son agentes de cambio
les quiero compartir un decálogo que yo
eran actividades que hacía
inconscientemente pero que se las quiero
compartir para que ustedes lo tengan
guardado
si quieres cumplir tu sueño persevera
visualiza ten
coloca un bolas en tu cuarto para cuando
te despiertes no se te olvide dónde
quieres estar las decisiones que tomas
en este momento impactan en tu futuro no
es cierto el decir que bueno es que es
ahorita no importa ahorita puedo decidir
esto tengo toda una vida no lo que
decides ahorita
te va a afectar en tu futuro visualízate
donde quieres estar en 5 en 10 años y si
lo que estás haciendo ahorita te va a
ayudar a dónde quieres estar después
acepta las oportunidades
y no existe la suerte la preparación es
la que te va a llevar al éxito la que el
en mi caso de leer pautas el hacer todo
lo que hacía para que cuando llegara la
oportunidad yo estuviera preparada y no
fuera un fracaso fue lo mejor que me
pudo haber pasado si ustedes están en
alguna área en la que sea aprendan todo
lo que pueden de esa área para que estén
preparados cuando llegue la oportunidad
y no se las ganen
piensa piensen en sus sueños convierte a
los en metas atrás en un plan para poder
realizarlos la diferencia entre un sueño
y una meta es que hay que ponerle fecha
atención afecto reconocimiento en estas
charlas me he dado cuenta que hablamos
mucho sobre el reconocimiento cuántas
veces no esperamos que el reconocimiento
sea externo que venga incluso de una
página de internet de las páginas de
facebook cuantos likes tenemos para
podernos sentirnos bien el
reconocimiento no viene de afuera el
reconocimiento es interno así que no lo
podemos exigir y no podemos esperar a
que llegue el reconocimiento es interno
la fuerza es interna y quien se tiene
que reconocer somos nosotros mismos y
les voy a decir por qué porque somos los
únicos ni la gente más cercana ni
nuestros familiares va a entender lo que
nos ha costado estar donde estamos somos
quien ha llorado
en el baño somos quien nos despertamos
diciendo porque no ha llegado esa
oportunidad somos que nos desvelamos
durante horas para alcanzar lo que
queremos y nada más nosotros sabemos el
precio que hemos pagado así que no lo
esperen de afuera no va a llegar
consciente en sí y hay veces que en ese
momento y en ese proceso de estar
pensando que lo que quieres no llega
independientemente de todo lo que haces
dejas de pensar en ti de lo que te hace
sentir bien
pregúntense que han dejado de hacer por
ustedes han dejado de meditar de caminar
de salir a bailar de tomarse un café con
las amigas que han dejado de hacer por
ustedes eso los va a hacer sentir muy
bien
ahorita hablaban también del miedo es
que algo y si lo vas a hacer algo con
miedo no importa si pero el momento de
hacerlo cómo le haces para no sentirlo
algo que a mí me funcionó mucho y se los
quiero compartir y ojalá también ustedes
les pueda servir es que cuando sientan
el miedo piensen en la persona más
importante de su vida piensen en su do
en quien los impulsa piensen en su motor
y pregúntense si quieren que esa persona
los vea con miedo va a cambiar la
percepción
pidan ayuda hay muchas mujeres hoy y
muchas veces nosotros no sabemos pedirlo
o no sabemos cómo dirigirnos con nuestro
esposo para delegarle actividades oa
nuestros hijos nos quedamos calladas y
luego viene la frustración y luego nos
quejamos y yo hago todo porque no
decimos que nos tienen que ayudar
nosotros también trabajamos pero si no
delegamos las actividades y tú ve por el
pan mientras yo hago la cena y tú
lavar los trastes mientras yo te preparo
el lonche si no sabemos delegar y pedir
ayuda y decir a ti te corresponde esto y
a ti te corresponde esta actividad
nos vamos a quejar y va a llegar a un
punto en el que estemos frustradas
porque sentimos que nadie nos ayuda
yo les garantizo que los esposos de hoy
si nos quieren ayudar
pero tenemos que hablarlo tenemos que
platicarlo para sentirnos apoyadas
hay unas estadísticas que dicen bueno
antes de comentar la cifra me gustaría
saber más o menos si ustedes me pueden
decir cuántas horas creen que los
hombres le dedican a la semana a las
tareas domésticas tienen una idea más o
menos
ocho horas a las tareas domésticas 4
otras cifras cuantos creen 10
a ver vamos a sorprendernos no o sea hay
hombres que ni ni una hora de plano en
la semana
dos horas
quién da más
así
dos horas
bueno sorprendentemente les dedican
alrededor de 15 horas a las tareas
domésticas semanales saben cuántas ahí
están ahí están están trabajando saben
cuántas horas la dedican las mujeres a
las tareas domésticas
más o menos casi a 42 horas
hay una gran diferencia
pero nosotras tenemos un gran compromiso
de empezar a delegar las actividades que
era lo que les comentaba hace un momento
nunca dejen de aprender y aprendan sobre
un instrumento una maestría lo que sea
pero el hecho de no dejar de aprender
los va a vitalizar mucho les va a dar
mucha energía los va a hacer sentirse
joven jóvenes en lo que llega a su sueño
consumen historias de personas exitosas
lean biografías vean muchas películas
basadas en hechos reales y eso las va a
motivar yo tengo toda una lista pero
bueno se me acaba el tiempo y por ultimo
agradezcan no sé si ustedes tienen fe en
algún ser superior en la vida en el
universo en lo que sea pero tengan fe
tengan fe porque si tienen fe créanme
que el éxito va a llegar en algún
momento de su vida
y por último todos tenemos la misma
misión en la vida y es servir y dejar el
mundo mejor de como lo encontramos
gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]
e